good
evening uh if you care to seat there if
you care to have a seat there's some
seats still left um good evening I'm
Matthew Spalding associate vice
president and Dean of educational
programs for Hillsdale College here in
Washington DC and welcome to the Allan P
Kirby Center for constitutional studies
and citizenship uh we're here this
evening to celebrate in honor our friend
and great teacher Harry Jaffa uh Dr
Jaffa was born in 1919 and as I'm sure
you know died di January 10th at the age
of
96 uh a young Jewish boy born in New
York he went to Yale and studied English
the time he was told not to go to
graduate school because Jews couldn't
get jobs teaching so he worked for the
federal government for a few years and
the first day that he did he met
Marjorie Butler the love of his
life jaff didn't like bureaucracy even
then so he decided to go to graduate
school anyway and intended the new
school for social research where he met
and studied with with Leo
Strauss when Strauss moved to the
University of Chicago he brought Jaffa
with him as a junior professor and a few
years after that Jaffa took a teaching
job at Ohio State and then later settled
at Claremont men's college in California
where he taught generations of
undergraduate and graduate students in
political philosophy and American
constitutionalism our event this evening
is co-sponsored by the Claremont
Institute where Professor jaff has
served as a distinguished fellow until
his death I to now welcome uh Michael
Pack recognize Michael Pack who's here
the new president of the Claremont
Institute Michael thank you for joining
[Applause]
us and Gina Pac who who is the more the
other half the more important
half uh Harry jaff is the author of 10
books including his classic crisis the
house divided and interpretation of the
issues of of the Lincoln Douglas
debates how to think about the American
Revolution American conservatism and the
American founding and a new birth of
Freedom Abraham Lincoln in the coming of
the Civil
War I first encountered Dr jaff as an
undergraduate at Claremont after my
adviser a new and untested professor at
CMC named Charles
Kesler recommended that I take a course
from Dr Jaffa on
Aristotle we didn't get very far in the
text
as I come to learn is often the case
from other
students but a whole new world of ideas
was open as we discussed at Great length
and then for years to come Aristotle and
Plato Mark Twain and
Shakespeare George Washington and
Winston Churchill and of course Abraham
Lincoln this evening before we continue
our food drinks and
fellowship with many many friends who
have gathered here we would would like
to have some brief remarks from a few of
Dr japa students colleagues and
family we begin this evening with
Charles Kessler who's the dingler dma
distinguished professor of government
Claremont mckin college and the editor
of the Claremont Review of Books
[Applause]
Charles uh thank you Matt it's a great
uh honor and uh pleasure to be here with
so many friends uh um old
friends um as as well as some new
ones uh Harry Jaffa was
pugnacious a word that he would have
been happy to tell you comes from the
Latin pugnus meaning
fist he was a Golden Gloves boxer in his
Youth and he never lost his love of a
good fight
whether in the ring the seminar or the
Public
Square to the people over the years who
tried to dance away from his public
criticisms he liked to apply Joe Lewis's
defiant quip you can run but you can't
hide as quick in his historical footwork
and as sharp as his dialectical Jabs
could be they didn't exhaust his game
later in life Harry became a
long-distance Competitive
Cyclist a sport that involves among
other things going round and round the
same
track racing against your personal best
as well as against your competitor's
time placing yourself and pacing
yourself in a strategy that culminates
in
Victory Harry played this long game too
varying and perfecting his arguments in
his long and largely successful though
he would never have admitted it effort
to revive political philosophy and to
reform American
conservatism the fate of the West
depends on the fate of America he liked
to
say the fate of America depends on the
fate of the Republican
party and the fate of the Republican
party depends on the fate of the
conservative
movement which depended you guessed on
him Harry would not fit well into
today's
academy uh with its crave and worry over
microaggressions and it's a codling call
for trigger
warnings Harry's aggressions were
decidedly
macro he fought over large issues and
high principles at least most of the
time he reminded me sometimes of the
Irishman in the
joke consider that your trigger
warning the joke in which
the Irishman finds himself in a bar
where a bloody good brawl is going on
eagerly he asks the
bartender is this a private fight or can
anyone join
in Harry got into more fights than he
needed to strictly speaking uh though it
was rare not to learn something
important from the
proceedings some of them were not pretty
and the tone some sometimes
disappointed as for example in the
exchanges with Walter Burns who died the
same day as
Harry Richard Samuelson uh nicely summed
up their public exchange of
letters as Harry fiddles while Walter
Burns at any rate Harry was a TIR
teacher who might have offered himself
as an example of the difficult problem
that the classics called the unit the
unity of the
virtues the virtues intellectual and
moral seem to belong together yet rare
is the man who possesses them all in due
Perfection yet most of Harry's debates
will live on and for good reason his
Socratic arguments taught us things we
needed to know and could hardly have
learned elsewhere at least not so
pleasantly and
persuasively above all uh is this true
of his two great books on Abraham
Lincoln each at the center of the debate
over the meaning and possibility of
human freedom and human
greatness I'm sure you you will hear a
lot about these books uh
tonight but crist's emphasis I Lincoln's
magnanimity his nature as a great so
man although dedicated to the principle
that all men are created equal this
nation Depends for its survival and
flourishing on a few highly unequal men
on political Founders like George
Washington and
saviors like Abraham Lincoln according
to Jaffa the willingness of Great Men to
enlist in the cause of the Common Man
showed that great men recognize the
limits or can recognize the limits of
their own
Humanity they won't play God to their
fellow men except in so far as their own
virtues are needed to serve the common
good but in serving it they dignify it
in crisis this thought LED Jaffa to
conclude that Lincoln had transformed
and transcended the American Founders
understanding of natural
rights will Mor Kendall in National
Review in a very famous early review of
Crisis wondered if this uplift promised
what he called an Apostolic succession
of high-minded presidents each eager to
raise his bited fellow citizens up to
his
level Jaffa answered the criticism in
several places most fully in his second
great book on Lincoln a new birth of
Freedom the long- awaited sequel to
crisis in which he argued that Lincoln
had served and fulfilled the founders
purposes he didn't have to elevate them
or overcome them the principles of the
Declaration of Independence were
inherently
high-minded jaffa's books brought to
sight Abraham Lincoln's greatness in the
20th century and beyond they reminded
conservatives that Noble political
actions are possible within
democracy and that democracy itself
sometimes demands them from Statesmen
soldiers and ordinary citizens
alike in other words Americans seeking
something worth conserving didn't have
to Pine for long ago far away
aristocracy or even for transplanted
truth
truth cogent compelling and beautifully
written these volumes demonstrated the
American sources of American
greatness Harry jaffa's reward is to
have become one of those
sources thank
[Applause]
you thank you Charles
um our our next speaker uh has known
Harry jaff since
1965 uh when Dr Jaffa was his freshman
adviser and he later says tells me that
he rejected virtually all of Dr jaffa's
advice so we'll have to make see how how
well that does him uh good friend of
ours many of you know Ken misugi he
teaches political science at John's
Hopkins University
k
well I did wind up taking Greek um uh
but about three years
later and a lot of Shakespeare as well
those were the two things he advised me
to to to to take up well thanks to
Hillsdale and the Claremont Institute
for allowing us um an this opportunity
to reflect on a great man the passing of
Harry Jaffa and Walter Burns reminded me
of a Jaffa witticism Burns and Alan
Bloom he remarked are the two faces of
rouso Geneva and
Paris jaffa's two cities were the city
of the best regime of course and
Claremont Claremont the home of the
western straussians or the Japanese
Americans while while Jaffa is indeed
the soul of West Coast Stanis his soul
resided in a body in Claremont and I
believe how Jaffa became Jaffa as Tom
West following Harry Newman aptly puts
it uh is impossible to explain without
knowing the effects of Claremont on him
in Claremont the Jaffa who wrote crisis
of the house divided uh flourished and
came to write his deepest book a new
birth of Freedom uh crisis I think uh is
actually a better book but New Birth
goes beyond it and thus acquires uh its
peculiar
distinction now the historian Paul
gotfried who gets so much wrong reports
an interesting story from the late
father Francis canovan a Boyhood friend
of Jeff and political theorist himself
Jaffa told canovan that he was going to
write a myth about Lincoln that he would
make everyone
believe now a myth is a false story that
tells the truth what Jaffa learned since
this disclosure to canovan is that the
whole truth is greater than what he
originally knew Claremont improved Jaffa
bringing his poetry down to the city
couple instances more could be elicited
be
mentioning his Suey generous students
Peter Shram and Bill Allen here
variously influenced Jaffa Ed earler and
John Marini were IND disp sensible as
was the late John
wreen I'll let uh Bill correct any
misimpressions I hold but it must be
said that at first uh Jaffa didn't think
Peter's project this Claremont Institute
idea uh would go anywhere nor did he
think once Larry a got the Institute
established as a going concern that
Larry should go to
Hillsdale again his students changed
jaffa's mind and I need not mention
Charles kesler's Claremont review to
focus on one example consider the late
recognition of the banful effects of
progressivism on American political
institutions and culture this was a
Claremont view not one of the pre Jaffa
Jaffa recall that crisis cites woodro
Wilson
approvingly Jaffa students reflected a
hopeful America Jaffa students in the
Claremont Institute have shown him wrong
on some important practical matters now
their focus is to teach America how
Jaffa was right on matters of principle
during jaffa's turn he became aware of
the bad effects of what came to be known
as Eastern straussian ISM on student
souls he saw it in his former colleague
Martin Diamond's narrowing focus on the
low but solid American founding he saw
it in some some of Bloom's effects on
his students and he saw it in Tom pangle
uh with whom he had a notorious exchange
parts of which I
recorded U now when uh pangle was up for
tenure at Yale William Buckley who was
asked to Rally support for him told
Jaffa he had heard pangle was a nichan
Jaffa responded with a half truth that
uh pangle was merely understanding n as
he understood himself
now Tom gave a couple talks in Claremont
back in
1982 in the first he declared that quote
Socrates didn't give a hoot about Athens
he actually used another four-letter
word now jaffas and his students
exchanges with pangle in Claremont back
then and years later in the pages of the
Claremont review had some temporary
effect on the way pangle disclosed his
grievances with America The Claremont
student and the Claremont students and
the Claremont Institute in particular uh
played a key role in Jeff's turn toward
America and politics in the face of
stigma and disdain I think this is the
institute's enduring role in American
conservatism having touched on jaffa's
Two Cities let me turn to this city
Washington D.C here one prominent
political man um honored Jaffa and
that's Clarence Thomas but the regnant
view of him in this town appears um uh
in the Hudson Institute celebration of
Harvey Mansfield a few years ago uh it's
uh it's it's on their website you can
view the the several hours Ross dait
opens his comments on on Harvey by
recalling his days as The Claremont
Institute puus fellow Jaffa asked him
whether it was true that Mansfield
stands alone at
Harvard after Ross agreed Jaffa asked
him but what does he stand
for the reaction on that panel George
Will among others was of howling
astonishment now amidst his Justice and
generosity uh one Mansfield remark in
his jaff eulogy in the Weekly Standard
stands
out quote one might think it impossible
to exaggerate the importance of crisis
of the house divided if Jaffa had not
shown us how in other books he made the
understanding of Lincoln's America the
solution of all to all difficulties the
combination of all good things democracy
and aristocracy ancients and moderns
prudence and principle the good in one's
own the the only dualities he left
intact were liberal and conservative Jew
and Gentile these he kept in order to
maintain or more accurately appease his
excess of fighting
Spirit now Mansfield might have been
channeling Alexi Dayville himself uh on
the Declaration from his letter to
shabal July 16
1831 the Fourth of July parade and the
reading of the Declaration teville
experience had moved him as deeply felt
and great but then came a quote
rhetorical herang pompously parading all
of world history to its consummation in
the United States seated at the center
of the universe it sounded just like a
piece of humbug in some fart
toille goes on I left cursing the speech
of fire whose gab and fatuous national
pride had dampened the Vivid Impressions
the rest of the ceremony had made on
me Harvey however was not merely
channeling toille because he's wiser
than that French
Observer but in light of jaffas and his
students work uh Harvey's claim that
Democracy in America is the best book on
America is simply
impossible now jaffa's most Grievous
error is that he didn't understand
Christianity Jaffer remained convinced
that Alan Bloom's essay on The Merchant
of Venice was
spoton in his later years Walter Burns
was active in his Episcopalian
Church
the gospel of Mark reports at the
beginning reports Christ's touching and
thereby cleansing a leper contrary to
Jesus instruction the healed man
reported the miracle and subsequently
quote it was impossible for Jesus to
enter a town openly he remained outside
in deserted places and people kept
coming to him from
everywhere and qu thus following his
Miracle Jesus is like the lepers forced
into the
desert I conclude by daring to address
you all
here fellow
[Applause]
lepers thank you Ken um Ed erer is
unable to be with
us as he had expected uh two nights ago
his wife has taken seriously ill uh our
thoughts are with them he he did ask if
we could read part of his remarks he
wrote especially for this evening and
make the entire piece available which it
is on a back table um and I would like
to do so and I'll begin uh Ed's
cerebration as he called it using a word
Professor Jaffa adopted for a book title
In
1976 about half through the piece where
he describes the development of jaffa's
thought following the publication of
jaffa's most famous book crisis of the
house
divided begin with the publication of
conservatism in the American founding in
1984 and culminating in the publication
of a new birth of freedom in 2000 Jeff
began to revise his opinion about
Lincoln and the American founding those
classical elements that he once
attributed exclusively to what he had
characterized in crisis as Lincoln's
refounding he came to see his elements
intrinsic to the founding itself
throughout new birth Jaffa argued that
Lincoln held no political principles
that he did not derive either directly
or indirectly from Jefferson and that
both were remarkably Arista tilian in
their view that human happiness was the
end of politics and that Prudence
measures human goodness solely by its
consequences this change represents what
jaff himself called his second sailing
much of which has been in addition to an
emphasis on the theological political
problem a new understanding of Lock's
role in the founding lock is still the
philosopher of the American founding but
understood now the way the founders
understood him Strauss of course
revealed that lock was a radical modern
who rejected both reason Revelation as
the foundation of moral and political
life but Strauss discovered the
radically modern lock buried deep in his
esoteric message there is no evidence
that the founders read lock the way
Strauss read him if we are to understand
the founders as they understood
themselves it is necessary to read them
in the light of the exoteric lock and it
is through their understanding of the
exoteric lock that the founders
understood the laws of nature in
perfectly Arista tillan
terms thus Jefferson's pairing of Aristo
lock in his famous statement of the
Declaration as an expression of the
American mind which draws all its
Authority from the harmonizing
Sentiments of the day whether expressed
in conversation in letters printed
essays or on the elementary books of
public right as Aristotle cister lock
and Sydney Etc is rendered perfectly in
eligible when considered from the point
of view of political
statesmanship jaffa's last pronouncement
on the subject was startling not only
for it Simplicity but also for its
profundity referring as he frequently
did to the second paragraph of the
Declaration Jaffer wrote after speaking
of our unal rights to secure which
governments are instituted the
Declaration of Independence goes on to
say that whenever any form of government
becomes destructive of these ends it is
the right of the people to alter or
abolish it and to Institute new
government laying its foundations on
such principles and organizing its
powers in such form as to them shall
seem most likely to affect their safety
and happiness notice that in the second
institution or reinstitution of
government rights become ends and these
ends are now said to be safety and
happiness the Alpha and Omega of
political life in Aristotle's
politics in a conclusion that is not
entirely hyperbolic jaff asserts that in
one form or another this metamorphosis
of locking rights into artian ends
recurs in many of the documents of the
founding I recently wrote that minds of
a peculiar structure those who believe
that there is an impenetrable wall
separating the thought of ancients and
moderns might object to Jeff's attempt
to identify Aristotelian elements in the
Declaration say nothing of his conf
conflation of Aristotle and lock
indeed a recent critic of Joffa rates
him for ignoring toille who our critic
claims is the author of the best book on
Democracy toille we we are assured
provides a useful corrective to the
founding warning us the manifold dangers
of dedicating regime the principle that
all men are created
equal kful argues that equality can lead
to either Liberty or tyranny but
understood as a principle of natural
right or natural law equality can lead
to tyranny only if it is wrongly
understood
toille never understood equality as a
principle of natural right but is a
faded
fact the modern follows or teville many
of them straussians seem to believe that
the Founder's dedication to the
principle of equality will inevitably
denigrate into permissive of equality
where Liberty will be sacrificed to an
overweening desire to abolish all
distinctions in the name of
equality at almost the same time that
teville was publishing Democracy in
America Lincoln gave his own critique of
permissive democracy in two notable
speeches the Lum speech in 1838 and the
temperance address in
1842 probably not since the ninth book
of Plato's Republic has there been such
a devastating critique of permissive
democracy as these two speeches both
which are subjected to detailed analysis
in jaffa's crisis of the house divided
but Lincoln's solution unlike tov's was
an appeal to America's ancient faith the
principles of the Declaration of
Independence Aristotle teaches that any
regime can be revolutionized democracies
can become oligarchies oligarchies
tyrannies and so on if regimes are to be
stable regime principles must be guarded
so that the slightest departures are
either anticipated and prevented in
advance or if not anticipated corrected
as quickly and unobtrusively as possible
revolutions and regimes are not
inevitable they occur when those who are
tasked with guarding the the regime
principles become negligent or when they
no longer understand the foundations of
the regime or when they believe the
regime's first principles are no longer
true or
viable in our constitutional system that
task of guarding regime principles was
assigned as general matter to the
Supreme Court it was to serve as the
nation's nocturnal Council if you
remember Plato's laws the Supreme Court
long ago ceased to serve that function
Jaffa often argued following Lincoln
that the constitution is unintelligible
without understanding of the principles
of the
Declaration without the Declaration and
is merely process without purpose only
one Justice of the current Court Justice
Thomas understands this and he
attributes his understanding to Jaffa
another Justice who is the reputation of
conservative jurist Prudence even
original intent jurist Prudence said the
Declaration is merely
fluff America has certainly become a
permissive democracy driven by
permissive
egalitarianism but this did not result
from the principles of the
Declaration as another conservative
jurist PR the late judge Bor
insisted rather it resulted from a
perversion of those principles it was
historicism positivism and nihilism all
elements foreign to the principles of
natural right as they were understood at
the founding that led to permissive
democracy the antidote is to return to
the founding
principles genuine principles of natural
right our ancient fate
as Lincoln and Jaffa have
advocated our critic to the contrary
notwithstanding tol did not write the
best book on
Democracy that book was written by Harry
Jaffa it is a new birth of Freedom
Abraham Lincoln and the coming of the
Civil
[Applause]
War uh our next speaker is Dr William
Allen uh Bill Allen was a longtime
colleague of Dr jaff is teaching next
door so to speak at Harvey mud College
Dr Allen is Dean ameritus of James mtis
college and professor ameritus of
political science at Michigan State
University Dr
[Applause]
Allen remember Harry
jofa as he remembered
himself Leo strauss's best
student in nothing did Jaa so powerfully
affect the imaginations of near
colleagues as in that claim of
Precedence perhaps though his putative
Rivals misunderstood the nature of his
claim rather than the affectation of a
teacher's
pet Harry joff's thinking turned on his
appreciation of what it meant to further
strauss's
project he believed that he had Advanced
that project more
substantially than any other of
strauss's
acolytes what he revealed at bottom in
his claim therefore is that he was
preeminently an
acolyte he never affected to achieve
being Beyond
Strauss he claimed only to realize the
goal of strauss's teaching having
experienced the conversion liken to that
of Saul's in the road to
Damascus jafa began with his focus on
medieval scholasticism writing tomis and
aristotelianism in mimesis of strauss's
work on myodes and
Plato he discovered in the method of the
disputed question an esotericism likened
to strauss's discernment of my monod's
writing between the
lines nevertheless we justly hesitate to
embrace this youthful
demonstration as a justification for
joff's claim to be strauss's best
student for although he continued to
return theism and aristotelianism in his
mature years he never explicitly
connected his claim with that work he
seemed rather to urge his subsequent
work as the
justification but Jaa seemed to mean
when he described his reaction to a
physically insignificant little man with
a weak
voice in terms of a conversion as
dramatic as that of Saul's was that the
unreflective historicism of his Yale
education crumbled away like the
shavings of a newly sculpted
ambition while that ambition must
generically have been to become such a
soul as the Great Soul that emerged from
within the little man if in particular
it seems rather to have been connected
with the acquisition of a new direction
or Target in the search for
truth he was like the woman of
Samaria who reported to her friends that
she had met a man who told me all things
that ever I
did dragging his Boyhood friends Francis
canavan and Joseph cropsy along with him
Jaa enlisted in the train of this
Messianic
figure key to understanding what jafa
became under this influence is some
appreciation of what he had been
before a cultural Jew of secular
ambition a patriot of moderately
Progressive
inclinations and an academically gifted
intellect he sought a pathway other than
that of his father's restaurant business
but not one that was intuitive to
him as his intellectual gifts developed
he was cautioned that there was no room
for a Jew in the US
Academy consequently he had no clear
designs on such a course prior to coming
under influences that made him heedless
of the obstacles that supposedly
obstructed the way he began to Envision
the life of the scholar as his own life
he too could be an honold bre or Harvey
Mansfield
Senior more importantly under the
influence of Str he came to imagine that
as the only possibility for
himself one of the stories that jafa
frequently told with a glint in his eye
was the story of Joe Lewis's response to
criticism of his work in support of US
military forces during World War II
Lewis was charged with ignoring the
severe problems of racial Injustice in
the US while he supported the country's
foreign Endeavors Lewis responded
according to Jaffa that the US had no
problems that Hitler could
solve this frequently repeated tale
speaks to influences that shaped jafa
before he came under the influence of
Strauss just as he had applied to Yale
though being advised that Jews were not
admitted he saw Joe Lewis's defense of
the United States in the same light as
his own expectations of the American
dream America had already become for him
a source of salvific
aspiration social indications to the
contrary
notwithstanding Jaa then United his
patriotism with the philosophic quest he
acquired from strauss's instruction his
conversion was not to
conservatism but to philosophy as a way
of
life what made Jaa strauss's best
student however was not the Embrace of
philosophy alone Java himself avowed
that philosophers cannot be
heroes a more particular development led
to joff's claim and that has to do do
with a specific bearing of his own
scholarship in light of strauss's
teaching jafa described his discovery of
the Lincoln dougas debates in a used
bookstore as an epiphany in which he
realized that these deeds and speeches
of Statesmen could contain all the
elements of a platonic dialogue The
Republic in
particular with that Discovery he opened
a window on strauss's teaching that was
to structure all of his work thereafter
that work was to unlock the door to
philosophy through reflection on
politics quite the opposite of the
conventional approach of unlocking the
doors of politics by reflecting on
philosophy this is the approach that led
Harry to see in the Declaration of
Independence the Locust classicus of
philosophic insight for the modern
soul in so far as the understanding of
politics is Central to political
philosophy then his claim to have
unfolded a comprehensive understanding
of politics is the key to understanding
his teaching as he said everything that
one needs to know about politics is
contained in the expression of the
Declaration of
Independence that we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal that they are endowed by
their creator with certain unalienable
rights that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness that to
secure these rights governments are
instituted among men deriving their just
powers from the consent of the Govern
that whenever any form of government
becomes destructive of these ends it is
the right of the people to alter or to
abolish it and to Institute new
government laying its foundation on such
principles and organizing its powers in
such forms as to them shall seem most
likely to affect their safety and
happiness it hardly Bears
observing that it was the prosecution of
this Insight that created the greatest
controversies in jaffa's teaching
career but it would be helpful to recall
that he had to be persuaded to produce
the bicentennial
celebration having an initial reluctance
that was influenced by awareness of
long-standing
friendships among the things that
eventually decided the case for him was
the discovery of his rival's personal
efforts to recruit adherence
which hardly seemed to evidence a
philosophic
disposition it was in that context that
he embraced
wholeheartedly Aristotle's preference of
Truth above Socrates as his own
watchword where japa stood on the more
abstruse questions of Strauss and
straussian ISM will perhaps require the
immense labors of Scholars to come to
unfold
it would be hard to conceive of Joffa
being subjected alast Strauss to lengthy
debates over whether he were an
atheist while a Yale undergraduate Joffa
spent a year in an extracurricular Bible
study which subtended a particular bent
toward biblical application in his work
if he were an
atheist he were an atheist with a
God as even are the Fallen
Angels not an atheist without God but he
was never victim to the intellectual
slovenliness that produces atheism
without God than which nothing could
more unsuit be attributed to Harry
Victor
Jaa thank you Dr Allen um Harry and
marger jaff are dived by three children
Donald Karen and Philip Jaffa uh and
we're very happy to have Philip Jaffa
here this evening who knew his dad well
since the day Philip was born if I'm
correct
[Applause]
Philip I knew my father as a father I
knew him as a teacher and I knew him as
a friend the role that was never very
far from the surface at all times was
teacher I can remember as a little child
he had this poem he used to like to
Pride very instructive for five years
old fivey old when you're time to look
before you cross the
street here lies the body of Michael O
day who died defending the right of way
he was right dead right as he walked
along but he's just as dead as if he
were
wrong
I would hear this over and over and over
again so one time I said Daddy why do
you like that so much without a moment's
hesitation he said Aristotle for
elementary
[Laughter]
school one day when I was
11 I was walking across the campus with
my father and I asked him a question
that no father really wants to get
asked I said Daddy how do we know that
God exists
we can't see
him my father
froze and then said come I will show you
very interesting thing to say so I
followed him along we walked for a while
and we went into a building and then we
went into an
auditorium and he turned to me and said
what do you see I said nothing the room
is
empty yes but are the lights on or off
they're on who turned them on
I don't know but somebody did
exactly when I was 11 I had another
wonderful exper again you just have to
uh imagine what the academy meant to my
father uh I went with him one evening to
his uh office at University Hall and uh
we met a janitor there and the janitor
had fought in World War I and told me
stories about fighting in the trenches
well at age 11 that was just the most
important person in the whole world at
that point so I began bugging my father
to somehow take me with him to the
office so I could talk to the janitor so
once a week we would go to the
University Club and have dinner and then
we would go to his office and he would
do his work and I would do my homework
and actually the janitor wasn't often
there but one night coming out of the
office my Dad decided to have some fun
with me so he walked a few feet down
stopped in front of an office and
pointed at the name plate of above the
office he saidon what does that say I
said Professor so and so he goes aha
that's what you think it says what it
actually says is often wrong but never
in
doubt so um the next week comes and we
come out of the office we go one office
down and we repeat
this what does that sign say Professor
so and so aha that's what you think
often wrong but never in doubt week
after week we played this game right
down that Hall and right down the other
side of the hall until we'd hit every
office on that floor and then we didn't
play the game any anymore three or four
weeks went by and as we came out I
decided to have some fun with my dad so
as Wei was locking the door I said hey
Dad see that name plate above the
door what does that say
so he looked at me and he looked at the
name plate and he looked back at me and
said what do you think it
says without a moment's hesitation I
said often wrong but never in doubt the
most incredible grin just spread from
one ear to the other he grabbed me by
the shoulder and said you've passed the
test now let's go get some ice
cream my uh my father another really
dramatic episode happened last year I
was in high school my father was a
difficult person to buy gifts
for uh he had other than
exercise but the one thing he treated
himself to was 12-year-old scotch and a
couple of time we that's what we'd get
him for Christmas every year so one
day he come came home from
class and he said uh Philip come here
we're going to pack up all this liquor
and get rid of it I've taken my last
drink I go wait a
second what happened he says today I got
in an argument in class with a student I
was arguing that marijuana did great ill
to society and was very harmful and he
was arguing back to me that alcohol was
every bit as damaging he said I have
never been so embarrassed in my life at
the weakness of my own argument I have
taken my last
drink and he did that was the last time
he ever took a
drink the uh just to share you know old
people when they uh when they get
towards the end of their life sometimes
have these really strong memories of
their early years and just a few months
before my father died he told me this
one wonderful story uh at age eight just
before his 13th birthday he was bugging
his parents to go down and work out at a
gym my father had gotten some kids books
pictures of Charles Atlas with big
muscles the only gym around was Klein's
gym on 42nd Street his parents said they
wouldn't let him do that until he got
his bar mitzvah so he got his bar
mitzvah and at that point his he and his
cousin Eddie would go down to uh
Manhattan once a week and they would go
to Klein's gym on 42nd Street do a
Weight Workout they would then go to his
father's restaurant the open door where
they would promptly ignore everything on
the menu in order in Chinese food
then they before going home they would
go to Union Square and listen to people
stand on soap boxes they really did
stand on soap boxes Haring the crowd and
my father's comment was on one corner
would be a communist saying government
is the answer the next Corner would be
an anarchist saying government is the uh
is the uh problem and the next Corner
would be a fundamentalist saying repent
the end of the world is near says here
we are 84 years later what has
changed these three themes continue to
resonate in the American political
system the wise person when faced with
these three options emphatically selects
none of the
above uh there's been some discussion
and maybe we can have a talk at some
greater length in add different Forum
about the difference
between the uh the crisis of the house
is divided and New Birth of Freedom uh
Tom West at my father's uh uh funeral
talked about the change in my dad's Fe
well I was talking to my father on an
almost daily basis as these changes were
taking place and my father started out
his
career uh with his work onism and
aristotelianism under the impression
that aquinas's goal
was to uh alter Aristotle to make it
safe for
Christianity he ultimately decided that
he had gotten it completely backwards
that
aquinus had set out to make medieval
Christianity acceptable to Aristotle and
the way he did that was launching a
search for the real Jesus my father
believed that the seeds of the
Reformation were in aquinus and the
seeds that he planted later caused the
split between protestantism and
Catholicism later led to the splintering
of protestantism and ultimately to the
reform of uh uh
Catholicism uh but my
father uh would frequently in his
lectures on the role of of of
Christianity in the American founding
settle upon certain texts and some of
that has made its way into his writings
and some of it has
not uh the the one text that that he
always mentioned about was when Moses
came down from Exodus when Moses comes
down from the mountain and finds his uh
followers worshiping the golden
calf what did he do well he separated
his people to those who were with him
and those were against him and they took
out the sword and they slaughtered their
own people as my father observed Moses
did not say aha free EX exercise of
religion what we call Modern democracy
became possible not guaranteed or likely
but possible at the instant Jesus held
up the penny and said Render unto Caesar
the things that are Caesars and unto God
the things that are Gods the idea of
separating uh religion uh from the state
did not exist in the ancient world now
there's another text that my father used
to cite all the time in his discussions
and that is when the Sadducees came to
Jesus and said Rabbi which of The
Commandments are the
greatest now when the Sadducees and the
Pharisees ask questions to Jesus it's
always a trick question and I'm not sure
now was the time to get into exactly
what the trick was but this was a trick
uh
question and Jesus responds by saying
Thou shalt love the Lord your God with
all your heart with all your soul with
all your mind and your neighbor as
yourself this is a misquotation of
Deuteronomy Jesus adds mind he adds
reason to the equation at that instant
the Declaration of Independence became
possible that is the instant in which
natural law was born
um my father also points out that and by
the way there are two versions of of
that in the gospel they differ slightly
because in in in Deuteronomy it's Thou
shalt love the Lord your God with all
your heart with all your soul with all
your strength but there's no mind and in
I believe uh uh one version in of the
gospels they they include strength and
one that leave it off but both of them
add mind they add reason to the equation
so somehow knowledge of God implies
reason so the uh the other part of that
and by the way that the the other part
of that is Thou shalt love your neighbor
as yourself well if you go back and look
at the phrase from the Old Testament to
love your neighbor as yourself your
neighbor is only the member of your own
tribe doesn't include anybody else Jesus
uh changes
both uh of those Old Testament uh
equation my father used to say that uh
the ascent of man from barbarism into
civility could be summed up in a simple
aphorism many gods many
people one God many people one God one
people and that is the rock on which the
Declaration of Independence
stands
thank you philli our final uh speaker
this evening is Larry AR previously the
president of the clar Institute he is
now the president of Hillsdale College
Dr
[Applause]
AR thank you all for coming thank you
for those lovely
remarks condolences to the
family uh when I met uh Professor jeffa
he was in his boxer shorts of
course uh I was a kid I was probably the
most ignorant young man ever to go to
study with him and uh I had given up
going to fancy law school which I'd
wanted to do since I was 12 years old
because I met one of his students Jeff
Wallen who's not here tonight I think
he's probably on his yacht he's grown
Rich um and he persuaded me that I
should learn something serious and Peter
Shram did me the great honor of uh
getting me to go to Professor Jeff's
house for the first class after I'd
arrived in Claremont and Professor Jaffa
emerged into a sitting room uh in a
white shirt
and white boxer shorts and black
socks and his hair was thinning and he
had a habit so he would always make it
he'd rub his head and he'd make it stand
up straight then he walked and uh it
emerged quickly that he didn't remember
who I was uh even on some explanation it
took him a while to locate that fact and
I thought goodness what have I done M
and then we got in the car and we drove
down and uh he kept asking Peter what
the class was about he couldn't remember
that I don't think he'd prepared very
carefully except
profoundly because then I remember the
first thing he said and I'll always
remember it's most my most Vivid
impression of all the many years I've
spent in
class held up the nickan ethics and he
said when people get Kim bone was there
a that and he said that when people get
to be old men like me I'm older than
that now they make a list of the 100
greatest
books life is too short for anyone to
read a 100 great
books so I have a list of
three I'll tell you what he said he said
the Bible is in a category of its own he
said Plato's Republic would have to be
included he said Aristotle's politics
would have to be translated some to be
fully relevant to modernity which means
maybe he was excluding it he said the
word Shakespeare one of his great Prides
to know about him and teach
him and then he paused when he said that
word just Shakespeare had hung there a
minute he said Socrates said that some
poet would come who could write both
tragedy and
comedy then he held up the ethics and he
said this is the perfect book he said
and in this class we're going to read
this
book I thought about that all my life I
thought about
it intensely at the time
and I thought what a challenge was in
that what was he asking us to do what
was he telling us to do what was he
showing us that he had
done uh he was uh Vain
and pugnacious and arrogant and even
vicious in many accounts of
him he was actually none of those
things he was
devoted he loved those things those
three things those the things in those
three books he
knew and he gave his life to
them he was insistent about
that you never saw anything so stubborn
as he
was uh I have the honor to be the person
most ordered about by him in
life
um uh his children who spoke beautifully
all of them at the
funeral uh explained that he didn't
really order them about it was his
students that he ordered about and me
most of all of all because I had the
honor to be the president of the
Claremont Institute and that belonged to
him and so I was told what to do an hour
or two a week for 15
years and
uh and the things that he told me to do
sometimes I didn't sometimes I didn't as
M sometimes I did sometimes I didn't as
Mugi mentioned a big instance came um he
was attacking certain conservative
leaders uh all of them friends of mine
then one particular one friends of mine
today they I haven't lost any
friendships over it and he demanded that
I write an introduction to one of his
attacks on one of them and which The
Claremont Institute he demanded would
publish and I did and it did publish it
but he didn't like the
introduction the introduction was too
nice and uh I had to change it and U you
can read it if you want to it's on the
claron insute website it's about Ed
me uh not long after this I was at a
conference in uram sat down beside me
and said at breakfast and said Harry
Jaffa is a bad
man and as I Was preparing to answer her
her husband sat down and I said uh well
no ursy he's not a bad man he's actually
a great man but he's very stubborn about
something and your husband has written
beautifully about it in one place and
less beautifully about it in another
place and with Professor jeffa that
won't
do I mentioned that to show that I was
not cowardly about
uh being prepared to go down the road
with Harry Jaffa Here We Stand
today but uh this one time he talked for
45 minutes I actually started timing it
I was on the speaker phone working in my
office and uh he started winding down
and unusual for him he said the word Dam
it twice in the course of demanding what
I do and I said uh and he he sort of
wound down and I said and I had not
spoken for 45
minutes and I said uh there's a pause
and I said have you finished he said yes
and I said yes you know it's not backing
down I said well Professor
you just talked for 40 minutes and
you've cursed at me and you've told me I
have to do something and I can reply
simply I do not and I hung up the
phone and
uh and so of course he called my home at
night which he often
did and he said um Larry Larry I can do
the tones it's always the same Professor
I never called him Harry I never will
Professor he said uh this is the queen
calling and I said the queen and he
saides he said uh and you're the Prime
Minister you get to do what what you
want but you have to listen to the queen
he
said my friend Michael Pack whom I'm so
proud has taken the job that I used to
have will not have this pleasure that I
had and he will be the less for it
although he'll be plenty
great uh Professor Jeff introduced me to
Winston Churchill and to Martin Gilbert
uh they had something in common they
both likeed
Churchill
uh Martin Gilbert introduced me to
penelopy
hton the mother of our
children uh they've both died in a one-
Monon period I've been going to funerals
for my
teachers both of them were fond of
saying that uh they were responsible for
my marriage and all my happiness on
[Laughter]
Earth and they they were and Professor
Jaffa who was assertive in a different
way than Martin Gilbert would also
explain that my children were also his
responsibility and he would explain this
to our
children including during times when
they were too young quite to figure out
what that might
mean Martin Gilbert has written the
longest biography in history we at the
college have the honor to carry on the
document volumes of
that Harry Jaffa wrote almost nothing
about Winston
Churchill two or three things in essays
including one special one called can
there be another Winston
Churchill the trouble with studying
Churchill especially if you study with
Martin Gilbert is you're not permitted
to write or say anything about it unless
you've read it all and it weighs
tons Professor jaff didn't read it
all but that essay I invite you to read
it it's the most wisdom that I have ever
found about Winston Church all outside
Churchill's own
writings what does that tell you about
him also couple it with the way he used
to order me about why did he care what
did it
matter it's this Focus that he had this
thing that he
loved he loved the good he thought he
could find it he wanted to serve
it he was so relentless about that I was
there bone was there that I'm sorry
Steven cambone great and distinguished
Man known as bone to his
friends in the summer of 1976 when he
made that big turn that Tom West and
Charles and Ken and and Bill have all
mentioned and Phil has all mentioned you
should read Tom West's essay on our
website about we have a Harry Jaffa
website up
today this turn was dramatic because
what it did was resurrected the
Declaration of Independence and the
institutions made pursuant as a living
thing
again it was very dramatic uh he would
talk to Phil every day Phil said today I
was riding bicycles with him with Ed
earler every day and uh we before we
rode he would read to me what he'd
written that day and he had learned some
things he thought that the account given
by his friends of the American
Revolution was false and the account of
Abraham Lincoln was was true and he
Harry Jaffa had not understood it and I
was there in 1976 in San Francisco at
the apsa when 400 people watched him on
a panel and you've never seen anything
so galvanized and so relentless in the
way he
argued it was just tremendous it was a
tremendous Act of imagination and
insight and it wholly possessed
him it was like the best classes he
taught you know the worst classes he
taught were him reading you a letter
that somebody wrote him often somebody
famous and then him explaining reading
his letter back and him explaining to
you how much smarter he was than that
person and I've had many hours of that
but those days in that summer and then
those classes which would happen every
term usually more than once when he
would get on to something and then an
hour and a half after the class was
supposed to be over everyone sat in
silence still because he had explained
human
soul what God is
like why a dog is a dignified being with
memory and intelligence and how you can
do so much with that but not what you
can do with
reason he carried all these things like
some great painter like church WIll
described the painter to be it was like
a scene that he could hold in his soul
and render it for you and he could do it
in informal conversation and in lectures
he could do it in little essays and
letters and he could do it in his
books they were familiar friends to
him he had command of them such as I
personally have never
observed Charles said he was a
magnanimous man and he was that very
much but I think if you penetrate the
real meaning of that you find out
something you find out that the
magnanimous man is an obedient man
Winston Churchill by the way loved the
expression the the term obedience and
applied himself it himself it to himself
many
times it's just that the
magnanimous if they have a soul big
enough to see and they
must they're obeying something that the
rest of us can hardly see at so high and
they are so stubborn and persistent in
the observation of that thing that they
call the rest of us to look at it they
help the rest of us to look at it
and indeed they punish us when we do
not great
[Applause]
man in uh
1989 on the occasion of his retirement
from
teaching uh our PI Sigma Alpha chapter
published the quotable
Jaffa hard to
find perhaps you can identify the target
of these famous Jaffa
retorts in your present state of mind
nothing less than a metaphysical 2x4
across the frontal bone would capture
your
attention if you do not know that you
are not a dog perhaps you also do not
know that I am not a fire
hydrant please keep your
distance and that ever classic you
pretend you're not you pretend you're a
more intelligent Mino and all pretend
I'm a less intelligent
Socrates Professor Jeff is teaching
mentorship friendship and yes criticism
profoundly changed our lives our studies
and our work more important Professor
Jaffer finally changed how we understand
America and its meaning and the
political thought of the West that
informed it and how to think about the
course and the crisis of the West and of
American constitutionalism
his work now carried on by as many
students has changed the academic and
public discourse about the founding and
about Lincoln and what it is that we
seek to
conserve and and so prepar the ground
for the recovery and restoration of
those ideas of statesmanship and what he
called the politics of
Freedom as his students we maintain to
continue this work thank you for joining
us and to Harry
Jeff